Actually, have you gone through the admission phase one training?
Yes, sir. I watched two videos of that. The state setup and transaction mapping and token money.
Yes, sir. But I have some doubts in transaction mapping, like I did all correct in my opinion.
But when I go into application data, I am not able to show the transaction.
For example, I am putting 1000 rupees in the registration.
So, it is not coming that we can collect that 1000 rupees.
And I am not able to go to the next stage.
As it is shown in the videos, it is written that you can go to the next stage.
So, I am not able to do that.
No worries, we will check those particular doubts as the ending of this particular meeting.
But before that, the basic part is clear to you.
About the setup, about how to do the application setup and all that particular part.
Yes, I know.
And what about you, Sarita?
Yes, sir. It is clear. I also watched the first two videos.
Perfect. So guys, today we will cover the respective advanced part of the CRM.
Basic things are known to everyone.
How to do the lead out, how to do the basic setup.
That part is easy for everyone.
But what the complex part is, now you guys are having the counsellor mapping part.
After that, you guys are having the admission lead logs part.
You guys are having multiple reports which are at the advanced level.
So, going back to the setup directly.
Because I guess everyone is clear about the admission leads.
It is clear to add tags, add follow-ups, add visits.
Does anyone have any doubts about this?
No, sir. It is clear.
Akhshat?
Sir, this one is not in the videos.
In the recordings, follow-ups are not there yet.
Like the Zoho integration, tags and counsellor mapping part.
We will cover the counsellor mapping part now.
My point is, how to add the admission leads page or follow-up, how to add tags. Is that clear?
No, sir. It is not in the videos yet.
It was not taught in the previous videos.
What about you Tanvi and Bhavan?
Sir, I guess this part has not been done yet.
It has not been done yet.
So, let's do one thing.
Let's cover this part as well.
Post that, we will move on to the further advanced part.
Basically, this part is clear to you.
You just have to come on to the application number setup.
Then, what sort of stages you guys need.
After that, for any sort of transaction, you have to give the transaction number.
And furthermore, you guys are having the admission leads part.
Sorry, the heads part.
You have to collect the heads.
Token money is clear enough to all of you.
Yes, sir.
After that, what we have is admission tags.
I will explain it now.
What was our admission source?
Basically, whenever you are receiving any particular of the lead or
if you are adding it manually, you have to select a respective source.
So, this source part will also be clear.
Yes, sir.
Now, what is the point?
Let's do the rest of the things now.
Starting with the admission tag.
Basically, try to understand that you have a lead.
And considering yourself as a counselor.
And you have to work on that particular lead.
So, when you are working on that, there could be multiple circumstances
as to what the student replied to you.
Student could be interested.
Student may not be interested.
Student could come for the visit to the campus.
And at the end, the student replied.
So, student can be a not interested one as well.
So, basically, what we do is, on the leads page,
or any page on which you are working,
taking an example, I have a fresh lead.
I have put a filter for not engaged.
I will tell you what is the use of filters.
What does not engaged mean?
That you have leads in the system.
But the counselor has not been done any kind of activity
with that particular lead.
So, after doing the not engaged filter,
after doing the not engaged filter,
you are having these red ribbons over there.
So, the leads where there is no activity,
those are marked with these red ribbons.
This makes it clear that this lead is untouched lead.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
Or for example, if there is any sort of lead
where there is some activity,
for example, there is an engaged lead,
either with the completed follow-up or the pending follow-up.
So, in that case, the ribbon does not come.
It does not come in this case.
Is it okay?
Guys, is it okay?
Yes, sir.
Moving back to the not engaged.
Now, basically, when you work on a lead,
you will select a respective tag.
Based on the conversation you have done with the student.
If the student is interested, may be interested,
after coming forward with it, you will select the respective tag.
So, if the tag is positive,
the system will ask you to add a follow-up
in which you will be able to add the date,
you will be able to add the time,
you will be able to add the remark.
Taking an example, I selected a date here.
After selecting the date, I put a remark here
and clicked on update.
So, automatically, my tag has been updated.
Now, what bad is,
I had just selected the not engaged lead.
So, my engaged with pending one is not showing.
By default, you have to use both the shows.
I have put it on coming forward with it.
I have put it on every tag.
I will follow the view here.
So, it has just been added.
Is this thing clear?
Yes, sir.
What are you saying?
Were you saying something?
No, sir.
So, this much is clear.
Now, the point is,
how did you make this tag?
And why did you get a follow-up call?
For example, if I put interested in this,
then I got a follow-up call.
If I marked it as not interested or something else,
course not available or not attending or not eligible,
then the system asked you for a negative tag.
Both are different.
You are putting a follow-up in one.
In one case, you are putting a negative remark.
So, how is this set?
In which case, your follow-up will come?
In which case, your remark will come?
Is it clear?
There are two things.
When you put a tag on any particular lead,
either it would ask you a follow-up
or it would ask you a remark.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
Now, the point is,
how will we set this?
Who will get positive?
Who will get negative?
So, you just have to come into the admission setup.
Click on the admission master and the admission tags.
From here, you can make admission tags.
Click on the add new details.
Whatever tag you want to give,
for example, I have taken a test tag.
Whatever color combination you want to give,
on the basis of your requirement,
you can give it by adjusting from here.
Now, the point is the labels.
The labels that come here,
your positive label and the negative label.
So, if you select positive,
then in that case,
it would ask you a follow-up.
Is it okay?
Yes, sir.
If you select negative,
then it would ask you a negative remark.
Simple, nothing else.
Nothing like rocket science.
You can create tags here
by coming to this page.
Different colors.
I will tell you one thing.
It is a little important.
Make sure you remember it forever.
What happens with us, basically,
if any lead comes in the system,
if it comes from the same number again,
then what does our system do?
It marks it as duplicate.
But how do you make duplicate tags?
That is the important thing.
I am deleting it now.
I have saved it here.
To make duplicate tags,
it is fixed.
You don't have to change anything in it.
Come to add new details.
Write duplicate properly.
There should be no space at the end
or in the starting.
After that, choose a random color.
After choosing a random color,
mark it as negative and save it.
Is this clear?
Yes, sir.
Now, what will you do with it?
Change the hex value of that random tag.
You have to zero this as well.
Zero it from here.
And then save it.
This will create duplicate tags.
Is this clear?
Yes, sir.
Good.
Now, the point is,
if you mark every lead as duplicate,
you won't even know
which lead came first.
The main lead, I would say.
In that case,
we will make a new tag.
That is Duplicate Primary.
Duplicate Primary will be extra in this.
Select any color.
Add labels.
Positive, negative, whatever.
In general, it will be positive.
After that, change the hex value to black.
Change it to black.
From here, RGB.
Zero.
And save it.
Is this clear?
Why are we making duplicate and duplicate primary?
Do you understand?
Yes, sir.
I will show you an example.
I added a lead.
For example,
I added a lead from a random number.
The lead was captured in the system.
It was created here.
Now, if I create a new lead from the same number,
the system will pop up.
The lead is already existing
But what you have to do for that,
you have to set up
a lead from any mobile number or from any other field.
After that,
if you still want to add a lead,
you will add it as duplicate query.
You will give names,
you will select your source.
I will tell you what campus visit rate is.
So, what did the system do?
Automatically, the first lead,
what did it do? Duplicate Primary.
And after that,
the lead we added, what did it do?
Duplicate.
Now, all the leads added from the same number
in the system will be duplicated.
So, what will Duplicate Primary do?
It will help you in checking
which was the first lead
with the same number.
Is this point clear?
This is really important if you are
at any college level
or at any university level.
Guys, is it clear?
Yes, sir.
Perfect.
Now, the point is,
this admission leads page,
what data does it show you?
The first data you have is
your fresh leads.
Whether you have leads today
or old leads,
no work has been done on them.
Fresh leads means your not engaged leads.
Then it shows you the leads
of those particular follow-ups
which are pending.
So, by default,
in the system, only two
statuses are ticked.
Not engaged or
engaged with pending follow-up.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
By default,
only positive tags are selected
because if you
mark any lead with a negative tag,
for example,
the student is not interested
or the course is not available,
then in that case,
the counselor will have
a lot of lead data.
For example, being an adult,
I have 10,000 leads.
Imagine if the counselor
keeps seeing all the data
which is useless.
So, what we do is,
if I mark this lead,
I can copy it.
So, what I can do is,
I marked it,
not able to take decision,
not interested,
tagged, remarked,
saved.
My lead is gone.
If I search this lead,
the system won't show me the lead.
Do you understand?
How did it happen?
Guys, will you say something?
Babay, explain why this happened?
Why is the lead not showing?
Babay, am I available?
Yes, sir.
Will you tell me once?
He is asking.
I will explain again.
What we did is,
we gave a negative tag to that lead.
What this page does is,
by default,
only the positive tag is selected in the filter.
So, when the positive tag is selected,
the negative tag of any lead
will not be visible.
So, what did I do to this lead?
I gave a negative tag to this lead.
So, what did the system do to it?
Because of filters,
it won't show the data.
But if I still want to check
if any lead exists from this number,
then I have two ways.
Either I can select the respective filter from here.
I selected from here,
not interested, click on go.
And search this application.
So, I got this lead.
Is this thing clear?
What did I do? I selected tag,
respective, not interested.
And from here, I selected status.
Engaged with pending and completed follow.
And that application was added.
So, I got the application.
This is the first process.
What is the second process?
I will reload it.
It applies the by default filters.
Then, you will turn on global search.
And you don't have to change anything.
Filters will be as it is.
You will not select any tag from here.
Not interested or anything.
You will only turn on global search.
And if you add the application number,
it will be visible.
I understand. Global search point
is also clear and not interested.
Why did you remove it?
Is it clear or not?
Yes, sir.
It is clear.
Any doubt?
Yes, sir.
Now, the point is,
it is clear that you can add tags from here.
Now, what do we have here?
We have to add follow ups directly.
You can add follow ups directly.
You have to add visit.
What does visit mean?
If a student visits the campus,
you can record it from here.
For example, if he comes tomorrow,
he will visit on the day after tomorrow.
If he comes the day after tomorrow,
From here, you have to add a note.
You have to make calls.
IVR should be integrated for calls.
Only then it can be called.
Otherwise, the call will not go.
The call will fail.
After that, you have to add a note
for the student.
You have to talk to the student.
You have to give specific information
After that, you will be able to
check the timeline of the student.
When the application was created,
who created it,
which email to check,
what email was sent to the student,
you can check from here.
All the activities you do in this
post that you have is
open WhatsApp.
Let me show you
what it works like.
Basically,
when I click on any student's
open WhatsApp,
my WhatsApp web will be opened.
My name is passed in it.
The name of the entity is passed.
You will be directly on open WhatsApp.
Your respective counselor's WhatsApp
will be logged in and he can directly
communicate with the student.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
Now, the student's name
can be anything.
Here is Sagar Babu.
I had booked Sagar Babu in this.
Sagar Babu is coming.
The system will automatically
take your number from there.
You will not need to type manually.
Is it clear, guys?
Yes, sir.
Now, the point is,
you can filter the data accordingly.
You have to filter the course-wise data.
You have to filter counselor-wise data.
You have to filter source-wise data.
You have to filter status-wise data.
Wait a minute.
Is this clear, guys?
Yes, sir.
Next time,
I will turn on the camera and tell everyone.
But the mic too.
This part is clear enough.
Moving to the setup again.
Is the tag part clear, guys?
Is there any doubt in the tag?
No, sir.
We will not do the seats part.
The source part will be clear.
Why do we add sources?
Now, the point is the source group.
In the case of source group,
for example,
we have made 10 sources in our system.
So, some entities
group the sources.
Group in the sense that
organic sources excite,
inorganic sources excite,
social media related sources excite.
Take an example.
I have created organic.
In organic,
I have selected website, my operator,
intag and
walk-in direct.
Then, I have selected inorganic.
Inorganic
is the spelling.
In organic,
I have selected social media,
WhatsApp,
online admission
and so on.
Then, we have third party vendors.
We have selected them separately.
In third party vendors,
we have career mantra, college duniya,
siksha planar, affinity,
all these are kept.
When you go to the source-wise report,
the data will be
combined and come to you.
Do you understand?
Inorganic is separated,
third party vendors are separated.
Others, which we have not put anywhere,
are separated. Is that clear?
Now, when you expand them,
you will get all the information
after expanding.
There was intag, website,
nothing. Now, when you print it,
it will be printed.
So, admission,
going to the source group,
this is the work.
Is that clear, guys?
Yes, sir.
Moving to the next point.
Admission seats,
not mandatory as of now.
Councillor mapper does.
Now, the point is,
whatever lead you get in the system,
it is assigned to some councillor.
Some councillor works on it.
So, from this
particular councillor mapper settings,
what you can do, you guys can
able to map the councillors
for the courses
as well and for the sources
as well.
Specific sources, taking an example,
specific sources selected,
reference selected, intag selected.
So, you can set multiple councillors
as well.
This source
and all the leads
from these particular
sources, they will go to these three persons.
Automatically.
You will not need to assign again and again.
So, what will the system do?
It will assign one by one, one lead to Sumit,
one lead to Himanshi, one lead to Deepa.
And on the process of round robin,
it will assign one by one.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
If any particular client
has a councillor
who works on all the courses,
then in that case, you will have
to select all of them
one by one.
After that, you will not make
multiple engineering courses.
There will be only one engineering course,
and one computer application course.
In that, you will select all the councillors.
So, one lead goes to him, one lead goes to the other,
the other goes to the fourth, and so on.
Okay?
Yes, sir.
What is this process called?
Councillor mapper.
Councillor mapper is the page.
From which process it is assigned,
what is it called?
Round robin.
Yes.
Now, the point is, round robin also
happens in two ways.
I will explain.
One is your all, another one is your device.
In the case of all, guys, what happens is
taking an example, you have four people in the meeting.
Suppose we have only three people in the meeting.
So, I gave all the information
Is it clear?
You were first, I explained everything to you.
Bhavya came late.
So, because Bhavya came late,
I have to give the starting information
to Bhavya again.
So that you guys come at an equal level.
So that I can proceed further.
Yes.
Bhavya, thank you for being the example here.
Right?
So, basically, what I will do is
I will hold the three of you for that time.
Right?
And I will transfer all the information
that I gave to the three of you to Bhavya first.
When all four of you come at the same level,
after that we will move to the next level.
What I mean to say is, suppose
there are three councillors.
They have leads of 10, 10, 10, 10.
One councillor came, a new one
was added to the system.
He does not have any lead.
So, what will the system do?
To balance the load of the other three councillors,
it will assign 10 first.
The new councillor will assign 10 first.
When he is equal to 10, 10, 10,
then one and one will start to be assigned.
Is it clear, guys?
What does all mean in the round problem?
Yes, sir. It is clear.
Very good.
Next, we have the devise.
Now, another one is the devise.
In the case of devise,
the system has no meaning.
Any councillor can be added anytime.
Whether it is added today,
or after 10 days, or after a month.
One person will have 1000 leads.
So, the system will not do
that the new one will be transferred to the new one.
What will it do?
As on date, it will assign one by one.
Is it clear?
This is important.
Sir, in devise,
suppose all the leads
will go to one person on Monday.
Will this happen?
No, I will tell you again.
In the case of all,
for example,
Friday, Saturday, Sunday,
three people worked for three days.
On Monday, another new councillor joined.
So, in the case of all,
all the leads will go to the new one on Monday.
Then, when your load will be balanced,
Friday, Saturday, Sunday,
and Monday,
then, until it is balanced,
the other three councillors
will not have any lead assigned.
But in the case of devise,
on Monday,
you worked for three councillors.
On Friday, you worked for three.
On Saturday, you worked for three.
On Sunday, you worked for three.
On Monday, a new councillor was added to the system.
So, the system will not hold those three councillors.
The system will assign them in the same way.
Suppose, the first lead comes,
it gives one lead, the second one gives the third one,
the third one gives the third one,
the fourth one, the one added on Monday,
it gives that one.
It will start the same way again.
1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4.
Is everything clear? Devise and all?
Yes.
Okay, this is all done.
Now, the point is
duplicate field master.
Duplicate field master,
the pop-up that I showed you
when I added the lead from the same mobile number,
it had showed the respective pop-up
that this lead already exists
within the system.
So, from here, you select the field
on which you want to check.
If we get the same field again,
then the system will show you the pop-up.
In general, our phone number
remains the same.
It is very rare in some cases
that your Aadhaar card is set,
okay, your
I would say
10th class roll number is set,
12th class roll number is set,
it remains in very rare cases.
Phone number remains mostly in cases.
Okay, so on which field
your pop-up will depend on?
It depends on this particular
phone number.
Clearance is?
Very good.
Then we have my operator config,
IVR, area B,
explain, we will do both of these later.
Let's move on to this particular
admission team.
Now, basically,
our universities
and colleges, in their case,
there are very rare cases,
where your outreach team is different,
inside team is different
for the admissions.
So, both teams do not share
the data of leads.
Okay, let's take an example.
Here is a senior mode person.
After that, he has two sub-branches.
Can you see what I am drawing on my screen?
Yes, sir.
Okay, take an example, here we have a person.
Under him, in the branches,
there are two teams, one here and one there.
Okay.
The senior most person can see
the data of this team and this team.
But these two people cannot see
the data of each other.
Okay, but you take an example,
there will be branches under this team,
there will be branches under this team.
Right?
So, this person can see the data of his team,
and this person can see the data of his team.
But this senior most,
he will see his data, his team's data,
this person's data, and his team's data.
But these two people cannot see each other.
After that, the people under the branches
cannot see each other's data.
Understood?
So, what we do is,
there are very rare cases in which
there is a team structure. Otherwise,
there is only a single most senior person,
and there are multiple counselors under him.
Is it clear? There are two ways.
Either you are a senior most person,
there are two teams under him,
then they are divided into two teams,
or you have a single senior most person
under whom there are multiple counselors.
If there is a single person
and multiple counselors, then there is no need for a team.
So, there is no need to follow the team structure,
there is no need to delete it and save it.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
Perfect. Now, taking an example,
if we have two teams,
one is your domestic,
whose team leader we have set,
is Sumit Kumar.
Here, we have added the members under him.
We have made Himanshi, Shastri,
we have covered Deepak,
and we have made Anaita.
We have saved.
We have added the other team for the external team.
Let's take the example of the external team,
that your Gaurav Sachan,
he is the lead.
The people under him,
for example,
Mani,
Pallavi,
Sukhpeeth.
Now, basically, guys,
what will happen,
you have two senior most persons,
one is this,
another one is this.
In his team, there is one person,
one person, one person, one person.
He can see their data,
and the Gaurav,
he can see their data.
He can't see the data among themselves,
counselors, same here,
he can't see the data among themselves.
And Sumit Gaurav
can't see the data of his team,
or can't see the data of his team.
Is this clear?
Team lead can't see the data of each other.
You can create multiple teams here.
You can add multiple members.
One more point,
taking an example,
Anaita is also in his team,
and Anaita is also in his team.
Now, what will happen in this case,
Gaurav can see the data of Anaita,
sorry, Sumit Gaurav
can see the data of Anaita.
Now, the common data between them
is visible to both of them.
In general, this doesn't happen,
but still, I told you with an example,
if a question comes up tomorrow,
you will say, in that case,
you will show the data of both of them.
But still, Sumit can't see Gaurav's data.
Whose data are they seeing?
They can see the data of their
common team member.
It's not that if we merge
Anaita here,
then we can see Sumit's
Pallavi data,
or Gaurav can see Deepa's data.
Gaurav and Sumit
can only see Anaita's data,
combined, whatever is common.
Are things getting clear, guys?
Or is it coming from above?
No, sir, it's clear.
Both of them will be able to see
the common data of Anaita.
Okay, the team part is also clear.
Okay, now from the team part,
I had left a point in the filter.
Okay, I clicked on the filter.
Here, the show member comes in detail.
Basically, what happens is,
you can filter from here,
which counselor's data you want.
Okay, if you want Deepa's data,
then Deepa's data is 253.
Okay, you want someone else's counselor,
you put Savita, Savita's data comes to you.
Okay, it's not there.
Now, the point is,
let's take an example,
Deepa is, okay,
I clicked on that,
I got 253 data.
But Deepa was in Sumit's team.
How much data does Sumit have now?
725.
Okay, but if I
turn on its show member detail too,
then what will show member detail do?
All the members in his team
will also get their data visible.
Okay, 1389 something.
Do you understand the point?
What happened to the filter when we detailed the show?
Yes, sir.
When our toggle was off,
in the case of off,
only Sumit's data came to us.
Okay, but
when we turned on
the members' toggle,
then what did the system do in that case?
It showed all the leads of its members
together.
Because a counselor,
it's a simple thing, a counselor,
is also working, but there are people in his team too,
so how will he see the data of his team?
He will see the data from this filter.
This is your show member detail filter.
Clear?
Yes, sir.
Very nice.
Now comes the admission
follow-up page.
We will do the reports later.
Basically, guys, you add any follow-up,
you can see it inside the lead,
but you need collective data
where all the follow-ups are added.
So you will come to the follow-up page,
here you will get all the data.
There are 27,912
follow-ups in total.
One lead can have multiple
follow-ups.
You can see the same lead mark again,
like this one.
The lead is same, one follow-up is completed,
one follow-up pending.
Here you will see all follow-ups,
here you will see today's follow-up,
today's follow-ups.
Upcoming follow-ups are yours,
which you have to complete in future.
You are in the upcoming.
Overdue follow-ups are yours,
which are pending follow-ups.
Then you have the completed follow-ups
which have been completed.
Here you can check counselor-wise
follow-ups by setting start date and end date.
You can check how many are completed,
how many are pending.
This is a report kind of.
Any doubts?
No, sir.
Now the admission lead log page.
Isn't it too much?
Or you can keep this much.
Tell me quickly.
Sir, it can be less.
Perfect.
Now we have this admission lead log page.
Basically, guys, what happens is
leads come to you from IVR.
Rest of the sources you can manage.
Website, landing page.
One minute, guys.
Basically, if you have leads
from any exercise source,
you can manage them.
But in the case of IVR,
you need call data as well.
When calls come, you convert
those calls into logs in the lead.
You are receiving the calls
directly into this particular page
and then you are converting them
into a lead log.
Logs are created.
But how to add them in the lead,
you will do it from here.
Basically, what happens is
we have to integrate IVR
with the respective partner.
So, the calls that come to the counselors
will automatically land on this page.
That is a received call,
that is a missed call.
You can check which counselor
you have picked.
By default, caller info and all these things
are blank because you don't know
whose phone it is.
So, when you call back
the student, then post
discussion with the student,
you will add the name.
I have added the name.
I have added which stream
I am in.
Now, the point is you can check
the recording of the call directly.
You will have to log in.
So, from here,
you can check the calls.
Is that clear, Rajesh?
Yes, sir.
Very good.
So,
from here, you can check
the respective recordings.
From here, you have to convert the log.
So, you can convert it from here.
From here, you have to reject
if the student is not interested.
If you have called
and the student has not picked the call,
then you can accept the call.
Here, you have multiple filters.
You can check the converted logs
from here.
So, you will know
how many we have converted.
You can check the pending.
Check the call status,
how many received calls you have.
You can also check the received calls.
If you want specific
counselor data,
you can also do that.
Sir, what is this source?
What is this source?
Basically, the source, the MyOperator
is your IBR partner.
So, we keep the source here
that which source leads to which log.
So, the source is MyOperator.
So, we set
in the admission setup.
MyOperator config.
Here, the secret token goes,
company ID goes, IBR ID goes
and its KPI goes.
We are not doing much today.
Otherwise, it will be very confusing.
As much as you have done, it is clear.
Yes, sir.
Sir, what is the purpose
of MyOperator?
What does it mean exactly?
Your MyOperator is an IBR.
So, the calls
that come to your counselors or
your admission team,
they are directly linked to an app.
If you have called for an admission,
then the call goes to an IBR number.
Then that call connects to your counselor.
So,
MyOperator is a mediator.
I would say the IBR,
the student who has called,
first the call goes to the IBR.
The IBR checks which counselor
is free at that time.
So, that call is transferred
to the counselor from there.
So, when the call
is transferred to the counselor
and the student creates it,
then the IBR mediator,
it keeps getting logs that
this call was hit, this call was reverted,
this response came that it was picked,
missed, how much time was talked,
then that data is pushed to us.
So, the IBR,
this is an IBR,
which is able to
get the records of those particular calls.
After that, the records of the calls
come to this, then it hits back to us.
In the advance one,
I guess a lot has been completed.
You guys are left
with the report sections
only.
I will tell you this.
Any doubts
in this part?
Do the Q&A session
because it is already
6.22.
Okay, sir.